welcome to the very first evan and
kaelin podcast
ever in our new house
[Music]
i always cut you off right when i end
the effects
rude and then now you turn it back on
when i don't even have anything cool to
say
how about we are in a new house i
already said that
yay so i think that
right off the bat let's hit one of the
very most asked questions
how is jube jube is doing good
i'm happy to report because that was
probably one of the things stressing me
out the most
about the upcoming move and we'll get to
the story of the move and everything
that happened
and all that but we wanted to right up
front say jube
is doing very well she enjoys the new
house she enjoys the new house she's
still getting used to it i think because
you know there's still boxes everywhere
and
like not all the usual stuff has been
unpacked although she does love the
boxes
not as much go crawling into them more
just like the tape
so we're often woken up by jube chewing
on tape somewhere
well i also think right off the bat i
think that the biggest question that i
have for you
after all of the stress of looking after
all of the the
like work that we put into this the late
nights
everything was it worth it oh yes 100
oh my gosh so worth it i am i'm i'll
just speak for myself but i am
so incredibly happy to be here at this
new place
with more space like we are in a whole
room
for streaming and podcasting a whole
room a whole
room we don't have to combine it with
the offices yeah we can set up lighting
and green screen
even better we can like try new formats
it's it's so nice
it's yeah i'm just so happy to be here
it's great for us personally it's great
for our business
mm-hmm like so also it's just like a
huge to-do
kind of in a way that's been weighing on
us for i mean
very heavily for all of this year
basically because we started
um looking in early february at houses
but i think even earlier
even earlier because we knew we've known
for a couple years that
we got gotta move we can't keep like
running the business the way we want to
run it in the small house like our
personal space was fine but the business
stuff was taking over all of the like
personal spaces going back a little bit
when was the first time that you knew
that we needed to move
like when you really started to feel it
um
i think a big part of it also is it like
a
it might be a little echoey in here it
might be a little echoey yeah i mean you
know we're still working on
setup this is early stages it's just
going to get better from here
yeah but i think one of the first times
was
when we made over our garage
and we ended up putting a bunch of stuff
that couldn't fit into the garage in the
breakfast nook
and then we made over the breakfast nook
and we put all that stuff into
the guest room and then we made over the
guest room and we put all that stuff
back in the breakfast nook
and like there was just like a series of
makeover room makeover projects
over a year a year and a half where we
were always
shuffling just a bunch of stuff
and some of it we probably could have
gotten rid of if we had had the time to
go through it but a lot of it is like
tools and camera equipment and
stuff like that that we couldn't
necessarily just
get rid of there was just no space to
store it
it never had a dedicated space it
ultimately ended up in the room of shame
aka the guest room which you guys have
seen
on the house tour and various other
stuff but i think that was kind of the
start of it when it was like
yay we're going to do a room makeover
and get our organization so much better
but then like we literally couldn't do
that without completely destroying
another room yeah
already here as we've been like moving
in and unpacking
it's been so nice just having like space
to put
things you know i'm like oh wow i'm just
so grateful to have a little bit of
spare space
you know it may eventually all get taken
up but for now it's amazing
i think for me when i first knew that we
needed to move and when it started
building
inside of me more and more was when we
first built the very desk that we are at
um the the rainbow led resin resin
streaming desk um and and i think i
guess when we first started the whole
podcast setup
you know and like we started adding more
and more things to
that office room and it started getting
more and more crowded and i'd be like
on my back working on something trying
to like go back and forth between the
two desks and i'd always have to like
squish you into our like desk katelyn
like pushing like like like trapping you
against that desk until i go back and
forth again and again and again and
again
while i grab this cable or whatever
and it's it's um i think that from that
point onwards as i kept on adding more
and more stuff
to this desk that we're at right now it
just got bigger and bigger
and like i felt more and more trapped
there
yeah i think that's when i was like oh
we need to move soon and so that was
how long ago was that a couple years ago
two years ago yeah yeah it's been
building for a couple years
yeah so let's get let's go go on to the
move so
yeah um we hired help which was the best
decision ever
quick question um for context
do you think that we'll release this
podcast before or after
moving vlog part two i think right after
moving vlog part two okay so they will
have seen
some of it so we can like refer to stuff
okay yeah
let's refer to all of it yeah okay cool
cool cool just want to keep things
straight
um like it's we're trying to record
things
the best we can but we also like are
having a hard time keeping track of like
what patreon
knows and like we're super behind on
posting you know
and so everything has just been a little
extra crazy it's all just going to get
mixed you know it's interesting i i do
sometimes think like
wow we're putting out so many so much
content in so many places like
what are we doing sometimes but yeah
what are we doing where what have we
said where
what have we just said to each other
many times let's just say it all
right now and if we're saying things
again
yeah okay so
how the move went yeah like you said we
hired help this was our first
uh like grown-up move i think because
before we can move from apartment to
apartment
or from apartment to house yes and so we
were only ever
dealing with an apartment's worth of
stuff
um and in our past moves we weren't
working from home
in this like capacity like we are now
where there's a lot of
work stuff well also when i i think it's
interesting when you're at an apartment
we didn't mount anything to the walls
really right no we didn't like we can't
we did a few nails and we patched it
with like toothpaste yes but like
that's like all we did we just put a few
nails in and removed we took
the nails out and put toothpaste on and
we're like yeah we're done we're ready
to move
yeah we had like friends help us move
some of the big pieces and their trucks
took everyone out for
like beer and pizza yeah
tradition at pretzels oh yeah yeah and
pretzels big puffy pretzels anyways
um but the point is like this is with
this move
we like i don't know i felt kind of
guilty hiring help which is weird
because like we never done it before and
it's like no
we can maybe we can but i soon got over
that when
was it guilty because you felt guilty
spending money or
yeah you know
as i do but um but like
we realized just how long that would
take us and it would be so impractical
and also our other moves i mean i guess
i did
um my first move when i moved in with
you it was a few hour drive
but um you know our move into
the old house was just like a 20 30
minute drive
yeah you know and we just have so much
more stuff now it would require so many
trips
like we would have we would have had to
take so much time off of making content
and we're already feeling like anxious
i'm like oh man i really want to get
back to making stuff
um even though we haven't i mean we've
taken probably the most time off of
streaming
just because you know we only post main
channel videos
once every two weeks streaming we would
do several times a week
so it's it's had like the biggest
noticeable change but
like we didn't want to have to like
skip making content any more than we
already are and that's the main reason
why we
hired out help to pack and to move well
yeah
the whole process i mean when when the
when the
the people got to our place it was three
days like
packing everything in our our house then
loading it
and then moving three days those three
days would have taken us
two weeks minimum at least
yes i think longer well because also
like driving back and forth so many
times because like
i can't drive like an 18-wheeler
gigantic
truck no like that we would have had to
like do
like four or five or six trips yeah
it would be a lot with a with like a
truck i would feel comfortable driving
and that's just like so inefficient yeah
yeah it it yeah yeah it just would have
taken too long and plus
um we also we didn't put
our old house on the market it's you
know we wanted to wait until after we
got fully moved out
just because it was so over packed with
our stuff we didn't think it would show
well
with all of our stuff in there and so we
also didn't want to put that off
indefinitely because
um you know spring is like the best time
to buy
um in summer and we don't want to have
to like oh what if that what if it
doesn't get to go on the market until
like
late summer because like we hit all
these crazy delays or whatever i don't
know
well one thing i think i'm gonna i'm i
could
just see us jumping all over in this
podcast
yeah let's just jump around today let's
just jump around okay one thing i wanted
to talk about that that made me think of
is
how fortuitous the timing of all of this
was guys
like you saw in the vlogs how
we got the house on the very
last day of the contract one thing we
didn't like
cover just because there's there's so
much that goes into buying a house
is like we it would have been harder for
us to afford
this house that we moved into if our
taxes hadn't have been filed
yeah that's true we had to kind of rush
to file our taxes this year
yeah and and like youtube income is like
it's not like a steady stable salary
yeah so the bank wants to see like our
our tax records because they don't trust
us
you know we're just like where does
youtubers what the heck are those
and and so like we filed our taxes
and then submitted it and then like got
approval then we bought the house like
it was like boom boom boom boom boom
like
everything was stacked right next to
each other with like zero wiggle room
and i'm just so glad even things like
like we saw
this house within a couple days of it
coming onto the market
we put in an offer like within 24 hours
of seeing it like everything has been
like without wiggle room yeah oh you
know let's go back even farther let's
talk about
the visit to this house oh yeah and like
what we thought of it
yeah because like we we saw like 40
houses like no joke
um in person and then we also saw like a
bajillion houses online
and i think that when
when when we saw this house i was
actually like in my head i was thinking
about the next house that we were gonna
see
because i was excited about that and the
whole reason why we took the trip out
to this area was to see another house
and and like the first house we saw that
day was such a disappointment
no this was the first house oh this was
so yeah yeah so oh
yeah so i'm getting it all mixed up so
our final trip
to the area to check out houses there's
three that we were gonna see
we made the trip for this one that was
in like
a really great area and it seemed to
have like all the
like check boxes ticked and it was like
like it seemed to be on the low side
price wise for what it was so it was
like all these things are lying and we
were like oh my gosh we gotta get into
that house
and there was a super super rush because
there are so many listings book
books our realtor or like the the
realtor uh the listing agent would only
give us 30 minutes in the house usually
you get an
hour but they were having so many people
only got 30 minutes
and on that day too when we saw that
house there's already offers on the
table
there's yeah there's already offers on
the table so we were like okay
we could just like literally just come
back from a trip to see houses but and
then this one popped up and we were like
we gotta go so we we planned the whole
trip around this
one house um the house ended up buying
had also recently come
onto the market and there was another
house that had recently come onto the
market that was very
different that was a little bit more of
like a fixer-upper yeah
but had more land and so
we came to the house we bought first and
we
almost didn't see this house we so
almost didn't see this house yeah it was
like
such a like close call of not even
seeing it
yeah and that scares me i know but i was
like
i think i i really like this one online
because i had seen one by
the same builder or something that had
like some similar
features that was like a coming soon
like it hadn't been built yet and i
remember
thinking oh man it's too bad that that
one's not built yet
um so then when this one popped up i had
already kind of had
a very similar house and mine was like
evan we should like just throw this one
in because it
you know popped up um but
uh so we came to this one first and i
was kind of like hey
what are your thoughts i'm pretty much
caitlin was like pushing this house i
was like this one's pretty nice right
what do you think and
after every house we visited we recorded
like
on the car drive to the next house just
a quick little video of our thoughts
um and at every house we also recorded
like
pictures and videos and this is all like
for ourselves for
for reference because um when you're
seeing 40 houses
like things really blur together and it
starts to go back and be like what was
our first impression or nice to go back
and refer to videos
but like with this one i could tell evan
was so not
into it i took one photo i took one
photo and you didn't take any video i
didn't take any videos
and then on the on the um
like video drive like you're kind of
like
and then we went to the next house that
was the next house was the one that we
had made
the trip out to see and it was
a hot mess utter disappointment utter
disappointment like
just one of those things where it looks
great in pictures but so much in person
was just
really shoddy like really not well built
um and you like like water damage that
was hidden
and there's lots of weird things like
the drainage
really rusty pipes and you know
foundation issues and
a lot of things like recently painted
over and i was like
there's so much like weird patchy fresh
paint
what are you hiding yeah what's going on
and there's so much that we could see
there's like
patches in the floors and like a
dehumidifier running and we were like
this
i don't know like it looks it looked
nice on the surface but
and we were like you know maybe there's
a reason why
it was so cheap for what it was um and
then we went to the fixer-upper house
and
you are so young about that gung-ho i
don't know
i don't know why i think i i think
honestly at that point i was like
we need we need to move soon yeah i'm
fatiguing
and i was just kind of getting excited
about various aspects of that house
yeah um but but then you know i i think
this is one of the reasons why it's so
good to have a really
knowledgeable local um real estate agent
and we had the best real estate agent
ever um and
and our real estate agent was like guys
you know
let me make some calls around to other
realtors in this area that know this
area and know this house and
and how easy would it be for us to sell
this house again
if you ever needed to move in the future
and i think that in the end that was one
of the biggest things that put us off
because even though it was
somewhat appealing for us we would have
to put so much money into it fixing it
up
that it would have been really hard it
would be really hard to sell and i think
would have been a
not the best financial decision yeah and
it would have
it would have been years of fixing it
and even though it's like yeah we can
turn it into content
we you know we don't want to have to
have
every single video be fixing up a house
sometimes fixing up a house stuff is
really fun and exciting and sometimes
it's just like
new plumbing you know what i mean and
like you can't make a great video out of
that but you still got to do the work
and sometimes we just want to do like an
art project or a science experiment
you know i think i think that's that's a
fun side tangent to go down on
because that's something we kind of went
back and forth on a lot and i think that
if we hadn't have so urgently needed to
to move and if we had been closer to
where we were moving
i think that i would have been much more
open to a fixer-upper yeah if we could
have like
you know lived at one house while we did
a lot of the bones
type stuff yeah but like we so urgently
needed to move we were like bursting at
the seams and we wanted to get
a new like there's also pressure of like
the interest rate is super super low
and the market's super competitive yeah
right now all of that
yeah so i think that i'm really in the
end the side tangent of like fixer-upper
versus a more like finished house we can
just move into
set up all of our lights and just get go
that's not to say we won't
like change up some rooms or customize
them or whatever but it's like not as
urgent
it's like uh you know oftentimes with
the fixer upper there's so much you have
to do before you can even move your
stuff in
you know like if you're gonna do the
floors if you're gonna like
repaint the whole house if you're gonna
you know if you have to scrape off
popcorn walls like we learned so many
things with our first house or knock
down a wall or knock down work all of
which we were thinking about doing at
that fixer-upper
and so it was interesting because like
like
i think you were like ready to make an
offer on the fixer-upper because it did
have some awesome looking back
i i'm scared of myself you were so ready
and i was like a little bit hesitant and
i was like what about that the first
house that we saw you know those look
pretty nice
yeah um and then once we heard from our
realtor like
with the amount of money you'd have to
put into it like you never
get that back selling it caitlyn brought
us this house again
then evan was like so caleb what about
the first house let's put an offer on
the first house and i was like wait i've
been trying to convince you
all day for the first house and now
you're like
you're you're like good to go like
you're ready like what
and then i got really hesitant but
katelyn was like
like the first house first house first
house and i'm like but the third house
third house third house i was like
actually first house let's do it and
galen's like wait what stop
i'm like wait have you thought this
through
and i mean i i guess yeah maybe it was
kind of
silly for me to to like be so hesitant
but it's a big purchase and like i want
to make sure that we're both
you know we both wanted to be both fully
on board before we
put in an offer you know i think that
like in the end
because the market was so hot because
more offers were probably going to be
put in on this house
soon and we wanted to get in and just
lock it down
we just like put in the offer right then
we just like literally right before we
drove home
we'd only see in this house once for a
very short amount of time we didn't have
any pictures no media no thoughts
captured on it
and we just did it yep every other other
house that we had like
considered putting in an offer we saw
twice except for this one
except for this one the only house we
didn't see twice was the house that we
bought
yeah exactly i remember we we put in the
offer
and then immediate basically immediately
had to drive home because
we needed to get home that night to do
some stuff for a video
we had like my little baby computer and
we had a hot spot and i remember we had
to like
stop at the side of like some gas
station pull in activate a hot spot
get on a little baby computer and like
fill out forms and sign things and send
them off and
everything as we were driving because it
was so rushed we never get offer in that
night
how much do you want to talk about that
drive are you okay talk about it
i'll talk about it i had a little bit of
a panic attack
[Music]
i i don't know if that's for sure what
it was because i haven't had a panic
attack before
for the next like 24 hours just because
you know
this this house is significantly bigger
than our last house which was very much
a you know
a starter home and a much newer house
and you know because of these factors it
was
much more expensive than our first house
and
like i you know tend to be the more
nervous one between the two of us about
spending money
and like because everything happened so
fast
and it was this like very big purchase i
just started having a little bit of a
panic attack on the drive home and evan
kept trying to do these calculations
to try to make me feel better like all
this math in my head and everything
and he was like well if you if you look
at it this way
and you you take out the principle
because you get the principal back when
you sell it
and you're just looking like the
interest in the property taxes and that
it's actually only
this much more per month and i was like
is this much more per month
oh my god
[Music]
um but yeah so i i had about 24 hours of
freaking out and but then well i think
that
one one thing that that ended up
actually helping
is we we looked at houses that
would have been good for like just
us living in more in this area that we
wanted to move to
and just us as in if we didn't have a
business if we didn't have a business
and then like
how much would like workshop space be so
like
like because because the amount of space
we need for work has grown
and we we just want more space to film
to make content
to to do more new things
and the only way to get that is to
either get a bigger house or to get a
workshop space
and we rented a rented one yeah
and then we looked up how much would be
like per square feet and how many
square feet of workshop space would need
and if we did if we did it outside would
need workshop and office nearby
like combo and we looked at how much
that would be per month
and that much per month would be about
as much of an increase in
monthly costs yeah as we were paying an
increased monthly cost
by getting you know this house yeah so
i do think that that's one of the things
that made me feel a lot better because
it's like the whole you know one of the
biggest reasons not the whole reason but
one of the biggest reasons
that spurred our thoughts of moving is
that
we need more business space and so you
got to get it one way or another
and we would rather work from home
should we
should we give you a preview now of what
business faces we're going to have at
the new place
yeah we can talk about it okay so right
now we are in
a room for um just just
all like various sorts of content
creation but this is like
um the the streaming podcast room we
have lights we have the green screen
we have all sorts of equipment and we're
also going to turn this closet
off to the side and a server room
finally yeah
then we have a whole arts and crafts
room where we're like it's an alternate
set and we're gonna
be able to stream arts and crafts there
and then we have
oh yeah i was just i don't know what i
was gonna add keep going
and then we're gonna have an actual
office
that's just an office and i think that
i'm pretty
pretty excited for that yeah because
fitting the two big desks and all the
other like
normal officey type stuff that we need
is we learned
a lot to fit in with the streaming desk
streaming
podcast desk and all the streaming slash
podcast stuff we need so
yeah dedicated just normal working
office
and it could be pretty for caitlin and
it can be pretty easy
because like like caitlyn does want to
and and can make an office really pretty
but then i keep on adding like
lights and green screens and all sorts
of other things
for the for the streaming and it just
isn't fully
no you can't have it yeah but i think
the biggest thing is like the space
and the space yeah and then the garage
workshop yeah
garage workshop so instead of having
the two like work spaces now we have
four workspaces yeah
and i think that's that's gonna allow us
to do a lot of good things and
get more efficient and up the quality of
a lot of things
and it's just it's so much nicer for us
not to be so cramped
because yeah most of the stuff we do in
our house is work
like related stuff so it's nice to have
the workspaces be a little bit more
and we can have natural light in our
office i know
i'm so that's one of the biggest reasons
i'm excited that in the space having the
um office and the streaming room split
because the streaming room you got to
keep it darker um yeah we have a moving
blanket over here covering the window
it's just like a moving blanket you know
it's a nice moving blanket it's a nice
uh kind of matches the wall color
yeah yeah it's navy and it's a navy room
yeah um but yeah those are the new
spaces
in our our our new house
um and i think that it's interesting
most of the space we added when we moved
from our
old house or a new house it's all
workspaces the number of rooms we have
for like personal
hasn't actually gone up yeah it's like
the
the rooms are maybe slightly bigger yeah
just because as you you know we
needed a bigger house to get these
additional rooms for the work stuff and
usually when you get a bigger house the
rooms themselves get a little bit bigger
too yeah
but yeah the like personal space hasn't
really increased that much because like
it's not like where we took up a i don't
know a new
personal hobby so the personal hobbies
are all work hobbies
yeah exactly you can double dip um
okay so so we talked about the house we
talked about like the like
barely visiting and buying at last
minute and everything
and then once we put in the offer on the
house that's when things started really
getting
real and i think that was everything
covered in the moving vlog part one i
think we kind of captured
all of the drama of that in that video
pretty well like
yeah like the going back and forth on if
we were gonna get it
and yeah well the funny one funny thing
and i think we talked about this in the
patreon after show
for that video um but uh
because everything was so last minute we
didn't think when we signed for the
house we didn't think we'd actually get
to go into the house we didn't think
we'd get our keys
because like the funds weren't supposed
to be like
be transferred because it was like so
late in the day and this and that
um and we were we were staying with
family and so we were driving back to
their house when we got a call from our
realtor um or a text
saying that the funds had actually
transferred and
and uh we could go to the house and so
we were like
and that's when we went and laid down on
the floors
we didn't think we'd get to do that yeah
i'm glad we got to have like a strong
positive ending there instead of like
i don't know what we would have done
otherwise i don't know we didn't fully
have a plan
yeah yeah for sure yeah okay
so then so we hired help which was so
great
um and i think that on the packing oh no
no
before we even get to the the help we
hired we did a lot to the house
oh yeah and some of it's covered in the
vlog mostly in like time lapse form
um but there was just so much that we
had done to the house and attached to
the house or
things like the editing and streaming
desks that we had built
in the room that couldn't be removed
from the room unless we disassembled
them
um so there's so much prep work like
pulling over some stuff that wasn't even
captured like we
had to pull everything out of the attic
yeah like
break down our storage shelves and take
all the stuff we had stored up there
um just so many things so many things in
the
garage that like i think the movers were
like
you guys are taking that and that and
you're taking the shelves
you're not leaving the cabinets you're
taking the cabinets we need them we need
all of them
immediately um so
um there's just so much breaking
down and i think even the movers were
like
well they were like oh thank you guys
for like
help helping to like break the stuff
down because we were in there with like
screwdrivers like as they were
you know they would load some tools into
a box and we'd like immediately take
down the pegboards and stuff um just
because there's
there's just so much to undo yeah moving
tip if you're ever moving it was so nice
like before the movers got there we
packed everything we needed
for an entire week and set it off to the
side and also i kept all of my tools
like my most used tools like
my my uh you know the the power
screwdriver
all the bits and then like a tool kit
that i i always keep that's my grab go
bag
with like you know uh a manual
screwdriver with all the bits
um a selection of wrenches that i really
like um that can grip a various
number of things we should do like
what's in evans
like tool go bag hex wrenches and oh
it's all the things anyways yeah but
yeah i think that was like
such a big thing um because we had like
i remember talking to your mom before
the movers got here and we were like
what tips do you have
um and i just remember her talking about
how
like crazy the packing day is because
you'll be like oh wait no no back then i
need that
ah this oh that and so we spent a lot of
time this is why we were up until three
a.m
like the night before they got here and
again later
because we um one we had to finish like
breaking down and dismounting stuff from
the house but also
prepping the stuff that we would need
immediately and so
um in terms of tips i think the tool bag
great tip
i think also things that like you might
not think about like i packed a bunch of
night lights
because when you're at a new house and
there's like boxes everywhere
like and if you have to like get up in
the middle of the night you probably can
like you're gonna stub a toe guaranteed
you know so we brought
night lights um box cutters uh
because you're gonna be like opening a
lot of boxes sharpies
sharpies sharpies and printer paper just
to like
because you might need it and blue tape
yeah you know bonus is gaffer's tape
not not as necessary i just like
afterwards just get blue tape blue tape
um yeah the tools the like
uh i mean for us we had some computer
and camera
type stuff yeah um we had bought just
several additional clear bins
from from like the hardware store just
to have
uh some stuff just open bins that we
could like put stuff in last minute if
we needed
again really easily yeah um
i'm trying to think of other i mean
obvious stuff like you know we like
packed bags and toiletries and stuff
like that
for a week um you know because of jube
we had
you know both her cat food types and
litter
and she has two boxes so we'd one of her
boxes and like a dust pan
you know to like clean stuff and like
cleaning spray we had a cleaning spray
um
all in our like stuff we'll need for the
first week
towels yeah towels like bath towels
you know because like what if you get to
your new house you got to take a shower
and you have no towels
you know um so we really thought through
and it's not the same as thinking
through like what you need
going on vacation or something um
because that's just like your clothes
and your toiletries and any
you know stuff specific to like where
you're going yeah
but the type of like normal life stuff
like
towels and cleaning supplies and box
cutters one thing that you missed that
you would have loved
is if you have had everything for coffee
in like a special box
the day they got here i was like evan do
you think i should it would it be
overkill to pack my like my coffee maker
some of my coffee stuff but we we
had so much stuff in our like we do not
pack
room we basically taped off the
treadmill room
um because that was the room that was
easiest to move things out of and turn
that into our do not pack zone
we had so much stuff in there the day
they got here we knew it couldn't fit in
the car
yeah and so we're like no no no we can't
we can't but i do wish that i had done
it but luckily
i borrowed some from our family yeah
so it worked out yeah but that would
that was that was a close
call that was a close that was a close
call yeah and then um
oh oh one one thing that like didn't
fully get covered in the
uh the vlogs is the whole garage
floor i'm not sure how we're going to
stitch that together we're recording
this before
caitlyn's edited i haven't edited it
moving vlog part two
yeah so the main really the only work we
did on the new house
before moving there is um epoxying
the garage floor because we knew that
once our stuff
is in there we just won't do it like we
know from experience
we know from experience because we
always wanted to do that to
our old workshop and we never did
because like you have to have your stuff
out of the garage
for like several days maybe more if it's
humid
and so much of our stuff cannot fit into
the house it's
you know we don't have a normal garage's
worth of stuff yeah um
and we have a lot of tools that we don't
want to get out in the humidity or rain
rusting
um and so we had that done beforehand
but
of course it was very humid it was
supposed to be raining like the whole
week and it did rain on our packing day
um
and like every day leading up to the
packing day
and so the the floor people were like
yeah we should be able to
we should be able to get it done um
and uh but then as it got closer
it was like it was too humid
and it was raining and because the
floors like extended out
past where the garage doors close like
that area was gonna get wet so it was
like they couldn't do the whole floor
and have that area be exposed to the
weather
and so we had to like last minute be
like okay just do everything but that
little lip
that goes out and just we'll we'll do
that later
but then it was still super tight when
we got there when we got to the new
house
um because day one was packing day two
was like loading the truck
and driving over originally we didn't
think we would drive until day three but
we drove
night the night of day two and so
um we like went to the garage and we
poked it
with our fingernail and you could still
indent it and we were like oh no
we we know what that means we know it's
not fully cured yet you know like
it shouldn't be able to be dentable with
that amount of pressure
and we knew if we moved everything onto
it just straight up
with the rollers and the harsh edges of
the metal things and
all the stuff we're going to be putting
on it would end up with like a
damaged brand new floor and that would
be so exciting
and like we didn't have a plan
until the morning of and the people who
did the floor
recommended this like stuff called ram
board
which is like a really thick but
breathable cardboard product that you
can lay out
to protect homes and and everything like
that and like
almost like driving carefully
just rapidly to several stores
all the movers are unloading stuff and
we just told them like hey do the garage
last but they had to
unload it all into the driveway because
they had packed it last so they had to
unload it first
yeah and so evan's like running all
around town
um to get this brand like while
caitlin's alone at
the house trying to manage everything
the move day
yeah and um luckily you got back in time
we
and we put them on there and then we at
very last
um you know the guys loaded up the
garage stuff onto the ram board
did it work i don't know we haven't
moved it
so hopefully hopefully what if like we
go to like
move all of our stuff off the board and
like the ward's just stuck
to the epoxy i can't think about that
it's not it's not an option i'm sure
it's fine i'm sure it's fine
yeah let's not think about that well
yeah and and the reason why it takes so
long like
knowing epoxy is because like if you
want
long working time that means long curing
time
so basically i'm not sure what because
there's
all sorts of different chemical ways
that epoxy can work not all epoxy is the
same
but generally the more flowable the more
workable the longer work time you have
with it
the longer it takes to cure so i think
that the full cure time for these this
garage floor product is 14 days
you know we had three we had three days
before we moved on to it
well it got most of the hardness done in
that time and it had formed a nice
top coat and and everything like that so
so hopefully when we
set up the garage and can move things
it's fine it's fine i'm sure
hopefully it's fine um
yeah so i think i think that that was a
lot of the behind the scenes that wasn't
covered in the vlogs
but or it might have just been covered
briefly yeah like we're
like we said we're not sure hasn't been
edited yet yeah
but um you know i think overall the move
went pretty pretty well
jube handled the drive really well she
didn't oh yeah
she didn't like the braking
she didn't mind the acceler she didn't
like the braking she didn't mind the
acceleration
and she was fine when we were going the
same speed yeah she just didn't like
anything that disturbed her yeah but she
she did surprisingly good like we got
that soft sided carrier
which i think helped a lot because she
already associated it with naps because
we had left it out for her to nap in um
because it doesn't seem like a carrier
seems like a duffel bag yeah
um and so uh you know carrying her out
to the car she was meowing she didn't
like that
um and uh when we first got started
driving because like until you get on a
highway you know there's always stop and
starts and
[ __ ] like that but once we were on the
highway like she was
kind of just chilling you know like she
was very quiet we would check on her you
know she was doing fine and she would
only
if then we would like have to break or
something and she'd be like
sorry it was more of a meow of protest
instead of like help me i think
not that i'm like an expert in
interpreting cat signals
yeah it was just like a little bit of a
like
annoyed slash kind of upset yeah when we
would break but then
we keep going and she was fine and um
you know we got to the new house that
night and
we um had decided that when the movers
were at the new house
we would set her up in one of the
smaller like
bedroom bathrooms because like bathroom
and closets because the bathroom and
closet were
um together so you could close off one
door and she would have a decent amount
of space much more than at the old house
where we put her in evan's closet
um just cause we like there were no
rooms with doors that were bigger than
that that we could empty out
to like keep movers out of it everything
had really big pieces that we needed the
movers help with
and we couldn't we could and you know
because there's no wiggle room in the
house
emptying any one of those rooms would
have made another room unwalkable
yeah and so we felt bad but we had to
put her in the closet
at the old house and she that was her
least favorite that was elise
and we would like visit her and she
should not want to be in that little
closet
but once we got here she had the whole
like bedroom and closet
together and into that room there were
one reason we chose this because it was
on the very edge of the house but
another
reason is because there's only a few
things that were going to go into that
bedroom
and so then once they were done moving
stuff into that bedroom then we opened
up
the closet and bathroom to that room and
then she had a whole room with a window
and some of her familiar stuff and then
she was like good she was good
yeah she was like i'm fine even in the
closet honestly she was good we made a
little blanket for it for her
like she had more space she was totally
good
yeah um which is great because she she
doesn't face that much change in her
life you don't really know how she would
handle it we haven't
yeah she hasn't moved in a long long
time like
seven years yeah a long time a long time
so um sweet and you know she's
11 years old she's not a young kitten
um so you know we were kind of worried
about the stress of it on her
but um it was also surprising how well
she did
at the old house like when the movers
because you know once the movers
were done for the day obviously like
open up the closet let her explore
but when everything was packed up into
boxes she was like having a blast
yeah exploring everything and smelling
everything and
so uh the empty house didn't bother her
really
um the house the the house with like
boxes didn't bother her it was only when
she was
in the club restricted yeah but i think
that now like one thing i wanted
to do with you is go on a trip down
memory lane
eight years ago when we when we made
our house buying for noobs guide
you know and and like see how well this
this
holds up because after buying our first
house
we made this guide because we just
didn't find
many resources that were written for
people
who are new to buying houses yeah yeah i
remember looking up so many
so many things and they were either too
vague or like too advanced
like they would just refer to stuff like
pre-approval and assume you knew how to
get pre-approved
you know what i mean um so yeah after
oh great the picture choices
i can only blame myself um
so we went through and we made this
guide kind of for ourselves when we did
it again but also to share for anyone
else who was buying a new house so
let's see what we wrote and we'll do our
best to describe
things for the people who are just
listening not watching so step one
was titled cash monies like what
i love is looking back is like caitlyn
put a lot of like time
just like we do now we she tried to put
a lot of time and effort to like make
the blog post like fun and interesting
and fun
to like sound like us like our voice
yeah yeah
um i think that is a good first step you
know because because
knowing how what your budget is for the
house really like helps define what
range of houses
you can do so step one cash monies 20
down 10 down figuring all of that out
talking to
banks and seeing how much you're looking
at looking up
um uh like utilities cost or talking to
family and friends in the area
so that you can figure out in addition
to your
mortgage payment yeah you know there's
like the principal and interest
property tax your homeowners insurance
but then all the utilities
so calling family and friends in the
area or doing research to figure out how
much that's going to cost
looking up different hoa fees um you
know there's all these different things
to consider that might not be obvious if
you're new yeah and maybe mortgage in
certain
insurance if you put down less than 20
percent you might need that
i think this this this this part holds
up yeah
i also like the beware of budget creep
because
that's real real big at the period
beware of budget creep after you look at
houses you'll start thinking
we can look a little higher than our max
budget because we can always argue down
the price so
your max budget creeps a bit then it
creeps a bit more and a bit more
[Music]
so yeah yeah i would say all i would say
that advice
about um i think the big thing is like
kind of breaking down your
your budget into the immediate down
payment but then also
the monthly and not forgetting all of
those things
all those things that add up well
especially like if you're going from
from an apartment
to a house an apartment we were when i
wrote this yeah that's pretty much like
all you need to worry about right and
well maybe maybe sometimes utilities
maybe some utilities are
included in it you know it depends on
well like
so it um at least like my old apartment
i remember like part of your apartment
bill was your water bill you didn't have
to set that up yourself you just had to
get like
internet and electricity you know what i
mean and then you're good
um yeah but then there's also things
like you can go down that rabbit hole
pretty far
like do you want to have like a regular
pest control do you want to have like
regular ac
maintenance you know like or if you're
doing that yourself what cost does that
add like you can go down the rabbit hole
pretty far
yeah our step two from the past was get
a pro
a good realtor and and that definitely
holds true um yeah and and
caitlin wrote you'll know pretty quickly
whether you get a good person vibes or
salesman vibes and you can look up
reviews online and and
you know thankfully for for both
purchases we we knew someone
who knew someone or someone we we we
somehow had a
semi-personal connection to the realtor
and you know that might not always be
the best but it worked out
really well for the two of us but i
think especially the big thing is like
if you're new to buying a house and you
might not
know the right questions to ask or this
and that
or if you're moving to an area you're
not familiar with
um having someone that can help answer
those questions is just super
super helpful yeah and also it's like
like
you have to balance like you know i
think a really good realtor will
be able to tell you like this is my
opinion as a realtor
and then like you know but like
no realtor really wants to tell you what
house to buy because
that decision should be your decision
but like you know
them being able to give you some
guidance on like
whether it's a good deal how easy is it
to resell if if you're like if i bought
at this price and i asked you to resell
it in
a year how easy would it be to sell like
lots of those questions like that those
are questions that they can give a
better opinion on
like what do you think about this area
it's like oh no the sun there's like a
ton of new construction you don't want
to be there
yeah or like yeah you know this you know
recently
blah blah you know whatever it is
they're going to know a lot like one of
the most helpful things from
our realtor this time is we were just
like you know we we were looking at a
super wide area
like like probably within a couple hours
driving
circle we were looking at an area bigger
than a city
yeah like big like like bigger than
houston we were looking at like a giant
area yeah
huge area and so you know we kind of
asked about some favorite neighborhoods
in the area that he was familiar with
and that gave us a great
starting point yeah so now um going back
to the list
oh getting pre-approved yeah step three
get it legit pre-approval
um i think that that is something that
we learned from the first time
and like getting pre-approved before you
even start
looking at houses because then if you
want to put in an offer
you already have pre-approval or there's
some houses that won't let you see it
unless you are pre-approved
yeah and also i think that that for us
starting to like
choosing the bank choosing your lender
forming that relationship with them
getting all of those cogs moving because
because sometimes you can hit snags like
like we did and we
we had started that process a long time
ago
yeah and and you know getting the bank
all of that information and keeping it
up to date with them and and all of that
doing that as soon as possible really
such a long process
if we had like done it like last minute
like if we hadn't done it so far in
advance
oh it would have been so stressful yeah
yeah so getting all your bank stuff
figured out
yeah and now step four
houses look at houses lots and lots and
lots and lots of houses
caitlin wrote this is the super fun part
and i think you still really did
i like i like i really like looking at
houses
i didn't like having to drive so far to
do it this time yeah it was it was a lot
of houses
so these are some of the things that you
wrote down um
that you were looking for last time okay
price and square feet
how many bedrooms bathrooms well first
first first
let me go back a little bit um because i
have some tips here
pictures and diligent note taking
a great tip because you're not going to
remember
all the things and so i remember when we
did our first house trip
we even i had like like this list we're
about to go through
i had a like a text note on my phone
um where i had all these questions
written down and then for every house i
would answer them
wow wow i know i was not as organized
this time
but you know um yeah so some of the
things
i mean i'm i'm not going to go through
all of them prices square feet bedrooms
and bathrooms does it have high ceilings
is there
a walk-in pantry is the laundry inside
or outside you know but one thing that's
interesting is like as you
own one house and then as you see more
houses you start to like
think of any more like more questions
like like knowing the signs of water
damage knowing the signs of like
you know has there been any foundation
issues and in multiple houses
i went up into the attic and i looked at
what type of insulation they had i
looked at what type of plumbing it was
like
is it galvanized is it pex is it pvc etc
you know so
yeah i wouldn't be like asking the
realtor like questions about insulation
or piping and they're like oh i don't i
don't know
i'm a selling yeah
yeah so i think that's just something
like like
maybe one tip that i could give is like
if you need to move by a certain point
go ahead and start looking maybe a
little bit earlier so you can get some
like
you know training wheel house little
looking
under your feet maybe because like the
more houses you see the more
like balanced it is like because like
you know
in an area you keep punching your mic
but like in in each area your budget
gets you different things and there's
different things you have to look out
for and everything like that
if you're able to if you're able to yeah
you know depending on the reason people
aren't moving they might not have as
much
advance notice like if you're moving
because your job is like
hey you're going to be moving here it
might be a little bit hard yeah
you know yeah that's true oh you're
skipping so much
do you want to hit this yeah because i
think one of the biggest things
um of things to look at in houses is
like being able to distinguish
like bones versus like the bones of the
house oh yeah
like the unchangeable things and then
the more easily changeable things
yeah you know what i mean i think that
like holds up
you know there's some things like the
location you obviously can't change
the size i mean technically maybe in
some places you can add an addition but
you can't do too much about that you
know some of some of the bones are
really
would be really hard or expensive to
change like it's gonna be hard to like
make the ceilings taller
you know um but then not getting
distracted by
things like uh bad carpet or bad
paint or like uh
you know you don't like the knobs on the
cabinets yeah and stuff like that i like
how you wrote it
that holds up back in the day pay more
attention to the bones of the house not
what it's wearing
look at me my clever writing clever
writing yeah
that's good um i also think that that
another good point that
you made back in the day was price per
square foot compared to other houses in
the neighborhood
that is a good point you do not want to
be the most expensive house in the
neighborhood
because the lower the value of the other
houses will pull down the value of yours
when it comes time to sell yeah so it's
like yeah if you're the most
expensive house in the neighborhood it's
gonna be harder to sell it
unless you're gonna live there forever
but that's not a safe assumption to make
all the time
we just always assume we're gonna move
again because we grew up moving you know
a decent amount so
i think that was one thing like you know
when we were moving i was like wow we're
finally moving i thought we would have
moved
earlier than this or something we both
lived in our last house
you know the old house longer than
either of us had ever lived in
any other place yeah in our entire lives
yeah and we just assumed we'd move
much earlier and we just didn't you know
just because i don't know
yeah so i think i think that was a
really good point
um oh this is another good point
um one last note about house hunting if
you can bring an experienced homeowner
with you
oh yeah yeah we often would bring like
one of our parents to come
especially if it was you know if it was
obvious no but if we were going back to
the house a second time because we
thought we were going to put an offer on
it
both the uh on our first house hunt
and when we were looking for this house
we would
like bring some of our family to to see
because they always point out stuff that
we
wouldn't see like i remember my dad
pointed out like
stuff about like oh the drainage around
this house is really bad look at where
these oh man yeah do you see where these
pebbles are
that's because that's like a gully and
we're like oh we never want to see them
yeah yeah you know it's like people with
more life experience especially like
yeah both of our parents moved so much
they both bought so many houses
that we did pick up a lot of great
knowledge from both of them
yeah yeah and it definitely helps
especially if you're new and then
step five an offer they can't refuse
yet any anyone can refuse any offer for
any reason
yeah but i think the biggest tip that
holds up from the offer part of it
is um one thing that we
we did this on our first house and we
were prepared to do it
if needed for this house as well but if
you're in a competitive market and both
the houses we bought
had like our first one had multiple
offers on it
um and this one there was another offer
coming in
later on the day that we were putting in
an offer
um and there were just so many houses
with multiple offers that we'd looked at
and so
anyways if it's a competitive market
one thing that i think helps is you know
you're putting in your offer and you're
competing with other people and you
might be
higher but you might be lower i think
writing a letter
to the seller introducing yourself
saying why you love the house because
this isn't the time to like play
hardball yeah you know
especially if there are multiple offers
now if you're trying to play hardball
don't do this yeah if you're trying to
play hardball don't do this
but if there's multiple offers saying
like hey
we're evan and caleb we love this house
we can't wait to like
have like run our business here or like
when it was first off house i was like
we're so excited
to be homeowners and like we just fell
in love with your house and we love it
for this reason and this reason and this
reason
it's like then it's a little bit more
personal it's not just a number
and i don't know if that's the reason we
got our first house but like i'm sure
it helped yeah you know um
i don't know i think i i would say that
holds up in a competitive market
if there's multiple offers yeah step six
apply for a loan this this is a lot of
work
i gotta say i don't even want to talk
about applying for
i don't have to but there's so much
stress
it's so much stress and if you haven't
done it before there's so many confusing
aspects to it i mean you're handing over
all of this information
all of your personal information all of
your tax and everything like that
and then like it's even harder it's
going up and down all the time and then
like
there's a point system and oh and when
you run your own business it's even
harder because it's like
there's so many more documents to like
prove that your income is your income
and
yeah yeah um and like but before you do
that
you might want to work on your credit
score because that helps you with your
loan
so there's lots of ways to improve your
credit score we
can't advise you on any of it you know
but it's
the the loan is like a big intimidating
part that that's important and it is
like
you have to make sure you have enough
time in your day in your schedule
to be able to take that take so much
time it's a lot of paperwork it's a lot
of work
yeah and phone calls yeah oh and then
step seven contract inspection
amendments
this ended up not being that big of a
deal for
our current house it went a lot more
smoothly but in our first house
we only had a three week closing and so
um we had to uh you know everything so
everything was more rushed so we got our
inspection
and then there's some really major stuff
wrong with the house that
the insurance company wouldn't insure us
unless we fix the stuff
on the house and so we had to like get
all these quotes and then argued on the
prize and this and that in order
to get this stuff fixed so that or get
it all lined up to be fixed
because that was the only way that
insurance company would interest i don't
remember the exact details but it was
like so rushed and so stressful
this time it was like the one thing that
went more smoothly
yeah well like the thing that went
smoothly last time
and this time was closing
and that that's an exciting step after
you've done after you've had the house
inspected after you've done all of that
then you do the closing and um yeah
you're signing a whole bunch of
paperwork but hopefully it's all done
right and
we just was like by the time you're
there signing stuff that's easy yeah
that's easy yeah you just sign the
things you do the things
and then you get the house yay yeah
i mean you know looking at it in list
form it's
it seems a lot less intimidating yeah
but like you know i think that the guy
is still holding it holds up you know
like i said it's kind of a basic
guide it might seem obvious to people
who've bought a house before but i think
it holds up
i think it holds up yeah
i'm just like so relaxed here in our new
place with like
it's just crazy here it's it's like
also i feel like i can stretch a little
bit and everything if we
turn off the background so they can see
the green screen do you want to show
them can we do that for the people
watching
turn turn off the background just to
show them the green screen is that
possible
i can do that yeah just just give me a
second i can just
just to give a little preview i'm sure
we'll do it when we do ah oh that's just
a green screen
i guess that makes sense but it's in the
new house y'all
this this green screen behind us and us
we are all in the new house
it's lit slightly differently and i'm
using a new program that's fancy
anyone just listening won't be able to
see this but look at that isn't that
fancy
yeah yeah um
so let's see uh we could answer a few of
the patreon questions that were about
warehouses
yeah so so before we did um any of the
move
at all um uh we we asked patreon for
like what they
kind of what types of content they
wanted to see us make around the move
and there were some questions that
people asked that you know a lot of the
types of content we have encapsulated
that and tried to capture that
in uh the moving vlogs but some of it i
think works better for podcast questions
yeah
so what we looked for in a house versus
what we made compromises on
this this changed so much
as the process went on like a huge
amount to the point where i was like
am i yeah you start questioning
everything yeah like am i
am i compromising in ways that i
shouldn't
like but like at the same time like as
you keep on going through the process
you get more information and you got to
trust the current you instead of past
you
that that made those you know
well it's really easy in the beginning
when you're just like making your
ultimate wish list and you're like
i want all of these things yeah i'm sure
i can find it
and then you realize that some of the
things are in direct competition yeah
and even if you had an unlimited budget
which no one
no like no one but like you know
i don't know like the point is even if
you had an unlimited budget
like you would still have to make
compromises just because of the
logistics
of like how cities are set up
and like where you can build houses it's
interesting looking back at like
we did a live stream where we designed
our dream house and it was so
far from like what would have been good
what we would have wanted
and what's possible yeah you know it was
like it was
very far off we didn't find any houses
like that
no not at all and i think also we um you
know
the the when we did the dream house
stream that was kind of like if we were
gonna build
um and we did consider building um
especially when we were just having a
really hard time finding
anything that would work um but
ultimately
one well i mean it's expensive to buy
right now and it's expensive to build
right now so it's expensive either way
but
building is so expensive but the um like
more than usual
but i think the biggest thing is because
we would be building in a city other
than where we were living
that just seemed so intimidating and
like we didn't want to wait another
year to two years yeah while things were
being built like we wanted to move
i think the biggest thing that changed
as we kept on looking at houses
is our workshop got smaller and smaller
yeah and the the the compromise that we
did with that
is since our workshop got smaller we we
subdivided
and we added like we added like a room
to what we were looking for in the house
for a like you know art workshop
studio inside because a lot of our
projects can be done inside like all the
you know acrylic pours or you know
just some of the things that we we do
can be done inside and it doubles as a
good streaming place
yeah but and one of the reasons that
that
is kind of what we may be compromised on
even though it's not
it's kind of like counterintuitive
because one of the main reasons we're
moving is
for business reasons and then we were
kind of sacrificing on a big business
thing
but i think it's because it was also one
of the harder things to
find and there's definitely
places i mean there are places with
workshops
but with the other requirements we had
it was hard to meet the other
requirements and that that was
almost always like the one thing that
was missing okay i'm gonna make a really
nerdy analogy
because that's who i am
um but like so you know like people who
play like
role role playing games and you're on
the character creation screen
and you like have all those sliders
where you can like
like increase their height or like you
know whatever
you know you're customizing the
character that's kind of like what we're
doing for
our house and there's like budget
there's house size there's workshop size
there's uh proximity to restaurants and
all of that
but like in this in this when you slid
up like
proximity to restaurants the the um
house size went smaller and the budget
went up you know what i mean
so it's like everything was like linked
and you can't just slide everything
out to the max because one it doesn't
exist and then the cost would be like
yeah if you want if you want more armor
on your character you're going to lose
speed
yeah exactly just for adding weight yeah
you know you have to you have to have a
well-balanced
character you have to have a
well-balanced house
because that's just how it is those are
the rules yeah this is the rule
so i think that like that's one thing
that we were struggling a lot with as we
looked for at houses like
way out in the middle of nowhere and
then right in the middle of the city
you know like we neither was ideal
yeah so we just had to find the right
balance with all of it
and be realistic about what yeah
and that made it really hard to look at
houses because we weren't comparing
apples to apples or even apples to
oranges we were comparing like
apples to shoes you know because that
like maybe apples to pastries because
the broccoli
magic broccoli yeah yeah okay magic
broccoli
um but uh yeah it was really hard to
compare because it wasn't just like oh
these two
you know x amount of bedrooms x amount
of square footage houses in this
area let's compare the two it was like
they were just so different yeah so yeah
there are definitely compromises made on
all fronts
but the most surprising one i think was
workshop space and we opted for a really
big garage
and some indoor space for filming yeah
instead of like a really big workshop
also one thing that was interesting is
we looked at some houses and i wouldn't
have even
expected this at some point but we
looked at some houses
that really had no yard or an unusable
yard for filming and we do a lot of like
back backyard experiments sometimes we
got to film in the backyard and we got
to do some shenanigans
sometimes we're swinging like spike ball
chains around and destroying cokes
or painting or you know whatever and
like a lot of the houses didn't have
that so
i mean you know as we looked we
discovered new requirements
for what we were doing and everything
yeah um so
what we were looking for in a house
we were so far off in the beginning and
what we made compromises on
everything but i think they're like in
the end
i'm really glad with how we left the
sliders and the right balance
of everything um you know so we didn't
get everything we wanted but everything
we got good enough
yeah exactly and like the best balance
we could best realistic balance
we looked at a lot of houses so we felt
pretty confident yeah yeah
um after the panic attacks of course
so um next question is how moving has
been while working full-time and being
our own bosses compared to our last move
when we were employed yeah that is
interesting because in some ways
it was harder and in some ways it was
much easier so
i think um the ways that was harder
is um we didn't have a separate
workspace
outside of our house that we could just
go to to work
that didn't have to be messed up in
order to move
so like um you know if the desks
that we had to disassemble weren't being
used for work up until
like the last couple days before the
move we could have disassembled those
super far in advance and wouldn't have
had to stay up till 3am
yeah yeah you know what i mean and um
or like our whole workshop we could have
started breaking that stuff down
or you know just started the process
over a more spread out period of time if
we didn't need to use it up until the
last minute
for working you know if we had just been
going to an office or separate space
that wasn't moving
that would have been easier but i think
like
being able to you know we kind of like
front loaded some projects and worked
ahead
so that we didn't have to take off too
much time from
our main channel uploads and um
we've been able to like put time
focusing on
the move and getting stuff set up like
the streaming room and things like that
without having to
like we could just decide to stop
streaming for a bit because
we needed time to do other things we
were able to compress
and expand and shift and you know
rearrange a lot
because we are in full control
of of everything to some degree yeah and
i think also like that
led to our decision to hire help
because when you're working for yourself
any like anything you do
it that is not work is directly taking
time away from work
you know and so it just made it make
more sense
to hire out moving help because
otherwise it would have been taking away
even more time from our work
yeah you know whereas if you're working
in nine to five then your personal time
and your work time is separate yeah yeah
yeah i think that makes a lot of sense
yeah because i mean
we can like we we can't hire anyone to
make the content that only we can make
but we can hire people to help out with
like a move
yeah unless we duplicate ourselves i
still need to work on that clothing
chamber
another question that we got was did we
find anything lost or interesting
during the move we found some stuff that
we were like we didn't get rid of that
like where was that we have like a
random random like speaker
that's in our room like i don't know
where that came from you know
um i'm trying to we don't really know if
we lost anything yet because we have not
finished unpacking so
we'll see we'll see yeah but i think
that one thing that we've been wanting
to do for a while
is just like you know sell or give away
um or scrap a lot of things yeah well
and we did
some of that especially with some bigger
furniture pieces
and some some tools and stuff
that would have been especially hard to
move we did that before the move but
there's also a lot of little things that
like um in an ideal world i would have
liked to
go through the whole kitchen and get rid
of all the you know any little
knickknacks
that we don't use or like cups that i
don't like or whatever
um but there just wasn't time so we had
to like focus our getting rid of stuff
efforts on like
physically large items um because that
was more bang for our buck like i could
have gone through the entire kitchen
and um had less volume than like one of
the big pieces
and that big piece was just a single
decision so
well we just didn't have time so we're
gonna do we're gonna like we're gonna
try really good to like
get the basics set up and then go
through everything
before we like put everything away and
get settled and don't do it
for another eight years yeah yeah i'm
kind of like in things like the kitchen
for example now
i'm putting up only the things that i
know for sure
we're keeping yeah um and anything else
is
i'm it's staying on the counter until i
make a decision about it and that's the
incentive to make a decision about it
because it being on the counter
bothers me so um so that's not really
answering the question was there
anything else interesting
no i i didn't i was just curious if you
had found anything i i i think that
because we
we go through our house so much and we
are kind of aware of what's there
fairly frequently um we found jube's
green mouse
oh yeah yeah it was under it was under
something furniture
found a lot of cat hair oh we found a
lot of cats
you guys so much um
yeah i don't know if there's anything
like you know what's good again we
haven't finished unpacking so we could
also find some really interesting stuff
um uh those those
the people who are who are uh watching
on youtube
might have noticed this but um caitlyn
and i right now are sitting in dining
room chairs because we
our office chairs are in our office now
we can't move them back and forth really
easily
so both of our butts are at the same
height and then because of that like
normally
i would be lower and caitlyn would be
higher but since our butts are at the
same height
yeah this looks hilarious i'm not sure
if anyone else noticed it before i did
but like i was
i noticed that but it wasn't too much to
do
well you set it up so it's set up for
evan height and then i come in my head
is only
halfway up so if you if you step out of
frame
because like with with you here then it
at least makes more sense
but with me here i'm just taking up like
half the height it's so poorly framed on
me
this is a perfect framing for me who set
it up
oh man all right yeah well i kind of
don't mind the dining chairs i don't
know
yeah i kind of like they're very minimal
in terms of like look
yeah you don't really see them too much
we don't have the green screen flaps
yeah no no flaps i don't know something
to consider i mean we can't use the
dyeing chairs forever because we need
them in the dining room but
now like are they are they comfortable
long term we'll have to do some gaming
sessions in them
yes yeah soon but but but
maybe also like gaming chairs with
narrowbacks
does that exist yeah there's one that's
pretty expensive
[Music]
it's like i'll show i'll show you
there's there's yeah
we'll we'll do that later
okay so um we also got asked about tips
and tricks for the moving process right
so i think we covered that pretty well
you know as we went yeah i think we've
kind of gone and we also
got asked if we have any plans for the
new house and i think we cover that too
like
the different rooms and what we're going
to use them for um
and i think that that kind of some of
our unpacking strategies
yeah and i think that we will make
videos for various
rooms in this house as we go yeah
but that'll be later yeah and we've
we've answered this or we've said this
in a couple places but i'll say it here
again
like i don't think we're gonna do
a house tour of this house like the only
reason we felt comfortable doing one
at our old house was because we were
about to move but by doing a house store
you're essentially giving people your
floor plan yeah the entire floor it just
doesn't yeah
for privacy reasons it seems not smart
but you guys will see the house in bits
and pieces but if you're like
how come you're not showing off the like
new house the brand new house yeah
that's why yeah so but but you will see
more of it yeah bits but for now
it's time for thing of the week
my thing of the week is something that
i've actually talked about before like i
i said
that i was going to get it and i got it
and it's great it's
rolling adjustable height work benches i
really like it and i think that in
general i i got like a 48 inch one do
you want to say which one you got and
where
uh it'll be in the link in the
description but it's it's just a
adjustable height manual adjustable
height
rolling work bench with casters and
everything like a butcher block top
butcher block top and it's it's great
because
you buy it pre-assembled yeah well we
just rolled it into a borrowed truck
that we were borrowing
and um just drove it back and then set
it down and there you go i mean
we've been so your original plan for it
was um because we want to build
new desks for ourselves
in the editing office um
because like we were just mentioning we
are very different sized people and
sharing a desk
at the same height isn't the most like
ergonomic so we're like okay we'll get
one of these rolling work benches
uh or adjustable height rolling work
benches evan can use it for a bit
figure out the height that works best
for him then i'll use it for a bit
figure out the height that works best
for me
and then we'll build new desks for
ourselves
with those heights and then at that
point we'll put the
rolling table in the garage as an
additional work surface but we've just
been
using it for so many things yeah like
rolling it around
as a work surface as we get the house
set up it's super handy it's so nice to
just have a rolling workbench
in your home is that normal for everyone
else
probably not but it's great for us
yeah um so my
thing of the week is um we
you know you like put uh drawer liners
and stuff
in your like kitchen drawers or
sometimes bathroom drawers
um all of the drawer liners it's either
contact paper which
i don't like doing sticky stuff because
it often leaves residue
or there's the um sometimes there's more
of a plasticky one but that
can be kind of slippery and then there's
like the grip one and the grip one is
what i wanted but the grippy
ones are always like an open weave and
so if you spill something
it's getting through your you're doing
it it's kind of hard to clean
i think i think i have a theory the
grippy drawer liners are actually carpet
they're like rug they're like the rug
pads they totally are
that was weird when you got a phone call
like the audio got weird no did you hear
that
my phone my dad is calling me sorry dad
i'll call you back yeah i'm gonna cancel
it like
it's creating electrical interference in
the system weird
we're overloading the system
um but anyways drawer liners yeah so
so i i was like it's gonna take a lot of
time to cut all these drawer liners
to put them all up i want to get the
right thing and i wanted something that
was grippy
but without holes solid so evan was at
was at the store and found a
toolbox liner that's for your toolboxes
that was the grippy material
and it was solid yeah we'll put a link
um
but it's the perfect thing for kitchens
too i think yeah and it's like
a very similar price and i even compared
it online you know and
like and it's it's a very similar price
works great for kitchens and it's solid
it's grippy and it's solid
it's the right thing i don't know why
it's not sold
as for kitchens and and stuff yeah we're
using in the bathrooms too yeah we're
using the bathrooms too for like
bathroom drawers
because it wasn't in the um cabinet or
drawer liner section it was in the
toolbox to adjust
um like workbench section yeah
so we'll put links yeah and that's the
end of the week but before we head out
uh i've just been you know we we get
emails whenever you guys leave reviews
and
we've been loving how much y'all have
been getting
in on the prank so for those of you guys
who haven't heard we have an ongoing
prank
um we we uh want someone else to find
the evan and caleb podcast
that doesn't know us from youtube
doesn't notice from youtube and get
really confused
so y'all have been writing great reviews
to
increase the confusion and prank someone
random who will eventually find this
but um we have one from owushio this pot
titled this podcast saved my marriage
and my banana bread muffins if you have
not listened to this podcast before
you've made it a grave mistake
my neighbor's cat recommended this
podcast to me via the cat dimension and
i'm so glad i decided to listen
this podcast shows you the nine keys to
happiness the answer to life
and how to make banana bread muffins
bravo
that's really gonna confuse someone it's
always smart to take recommendations
from your neighbor's cat okay and then
we have one
titled uh visionary from baby
maggie or baby bee maggie if podcasts
could be in moma
this one would be i now have the
knowledge to circumnavigate the globe
develop
new species of fruit and select the best
cat listen and enchant the world with
your new knowledge
y'all are funny i like it thank you i
like it thank you for furthering our
prank and confusing
anyone who happens to randomly stumble
upon us
and thank you for joining us for the
very first podcast
in the new house and we'll look forward
to seeing you
in the next one bye bye
you